merci monsieur dupont l'ordre du jour
appelle la question numéro 324 de
monsieur alain gournac à madame la
ministre de l'artisanat du commerce et
du tourisme
merci monsieur le président mes chers
collègues
madame la ministre le pain français que
l'on nous envie un peu partout dans le
monde et qui participe à la qualité de
la table française est une spécificité
qui lui doit être abandonné et qu'il
faut pour cela tu es fendre et soutenir
l'appellation boulanger comme vous le
savez ne peut être utilisé que par les
artisans qui à partir de matières
premières choisi un sur eux mêmes le
pétrissage de la pâte sa fermentation et
sa mise en forme ainsi que la cuisson du
pain sur le lieu sur le lieu de vente au
consommateur final
or il semble que les consommateurs ne
soient pas bien informés de cette réelle
et que celle ci ne soit pas toujours
correctement respecté
concernant la viennoiserie par exemple
sincèrement certains membres de la
profession affirme qu'ap a dû sur deux
vendues en boulangerie serait de
fabrication industrielle d'autres
minimisant la réalité affirme au
contraire que l'utilisation de produits
industriels congelés serait marginal
produire français manu miss c'est
notamment ce domaine produire selon les
règles et les méthodes qui ont concouru
à la qualité de nos produits
et pourtant et partant à leur notoriété
aussi j'aimerais connaître la situation
exacte concernant le mode de fabrication
des produits vendus en boulangerie
pouvez vous nous éclairer à ce sujet
d'autre part ne conviendrait-il pas pour
défendre cet artisanat de la boulangerie
sur l'ensemble de notre territoire ou à
l'étranger
assurer une véritable promotion des
boulangeries méritant leur appellation
par la mise en place d'une signalétique
efficace régime est sans ambiguïté aux
yeux des consommateurs
le sénat organisé la semaine dernière la
remise des prix du concours national
des meilleurs apprentis de france c'est
une magnifique manifestation qui nous
permet de rencontrer chaque année une
jeunesse dans notre pays peut
s'enorgueillir
permettez moi de vous dire le ministre
que c'est certes par souci de la défense
de cette grande tradition française de
la boulangerie que je vous pose
aujourd'hui la question mais également
par respect pour l'engagement de ces
jeunes apprentis
par respect pour le formidable travail
de leur maître d'apprentissage par
respect aussi pour le soutien et
l'encouragement que leur apportent leurs
parents dont la fierté faisait plaisir à
voir mercredi dernier je vous remercie
par avance de votre réponse merci
monsieur gournac la parole est à madame
sylvia pinel ministre de l'artisanat du
commerce et du tourisme
merci monsieur le président messieurs
les sénateurs monsieur le sénateur je
partage pleinement votre regard sur le
travail de nos boulangers sur le rôle de
ce secteur dans notre histoire notre
réputation notre rayonnement le secteur
de la boulangerie ses trente-deux mille
entreprises avec un commerce de détail
alimentaire de proximité qui est présent
sur l'ensemble du territoire qui génère
environ 11 milliards d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires annuel et représente 160
mille salariés
chaque jour plus de 12 millions de
clients poussent la porte d'une
boulangerie c'est bien parce que l'état
et le pays tout entier est fier de cette
spécificité que la loi du 25 mai 1998
détermine les conditions juridiques de
l'exercice de la profession d'artisan
boulanger
en effet depuis cette date l'appellation
de boulanger et l'enseigne de
boulangerie bénéficient d'une protection
codifié dans le code de la consommation
ainsi vous l'avez rappelé le code de la
consommation indique que les
professionnels ne peuvent utiliser
l'appellation de boulanger et l'enseigne
commercial de boulangerie s'il n'assure
pas eux mêmes à partir de matières
premières choisi le pétrissage de la
pâte sa fermentation et sa mise en forme
ainsi que la cuisson du pain sur le lieu
de vente due au consommateur final
il est également précisé que les
produits ne peuvent à aucun stade de
production ou de la vente être surgelés
ou congelés ces dispositions
s'appliquent également
lorsque le pain est vendu de façon
itinérante par le professionnel des
sanctions pénales assez sévères sont
prévues par la loi puisque l'infraction
à cette législation est passible d'une
peine de prison qui peut aller jusqu'à
deux ans et d'une amende de 37 mille
cinq cents euros
les viennoiseries qui sont vendues en
boulangerie bénéficie du même gage de
qualité et par ailleurs afin de
valoriser la fabrication maison
la profession travaille actuellement à
la réalisation d'un code des usages
incitant à la fabrication maison et qui
permettra d'améliorer l'information des
clients
le cadre juridique monsieur le sénateur
et là il est protecteur pour cette
profession à laquelle nous sommes tous
très attachés et le gouvernent
gouvernement fera tout pour faire
respecter la législation en vigueur
l'enjeu de la profession aujourd'hui et
vous l'avez souligné est de valoriser
ces métiers passionnants mais qui sont
confrontés comme les autres métiers de
l'artisanat à la nécessité d'attirer des
jeunes et donc de les valoriser
vous avez évoqué la manifestation qui a
eu lieu la semaine dernière ici même au
sénat et le gouvernement partage
effectivement cette ambition d'attirer
de plus en plus de jeunes vers ces
métiers passionnants et associe à ses
remerciements ce que vous avez formulées
bien sûr aux maîtres d'apprentissage et
à l'ensemble des structures qui
permettent à nos jeunes de s'orienter de
se former dans de bonnes conditions pour
être demain des professionnels qui
auront ce souci de qualité ce souci de
produire pour rassurer le consommateur
et c'est finalement ces mesures
s'inscrivent dans le pacte pour
l'artisanat que j'ai présenté en janvier
dernier qui contient des dispositions
pour la valorisation des métiers leur
attractivité mais aussi sur la formation
de s'aimer à ces métiers avec une
réforme de l'orientation avec des
campagnes ciblées de promotion des
savoir faire
plusieurs y concourt pour attirer les
jeunes mais aussi certaines
manifestations organisées par les
professionnels je pense à la fête du
pain je pense à la fête de la
gastronomie qui sont des lieux où nous
pouvons évidemment remarqué ses savoir
faire d'excellence qui sont nombreux
dans notre pays enfin je précise que
dans le cadre du pacte pour l'artisanat
j'ai initié un travail sur le statut de
l'artisan qui doit à la fois permettent
de clarifier la qualité et la
qualification qui est requise pour
exercer ces métiers ces métiers qui sont
très utiles sur l'ensemble du territoire
national
vous le voyez monsieur le sénateur les
préoccupations du gouvernement
rejoignent les vôtres et j'espère que
sur ces sujets sur le statut de
l'artisan la valorisation des métiers
je pourrai compter sur le soutien du
sénat et de la représentation nationale
merci madame la ministre monsieur
gournac d'abord monsieur le président je
voudrais remercier madame la ministre
parce qu'elle a été très clair il faut
pas de désaccord entre nous moi je
venais simplement vers elle parce que ça
c'est l'idéal
vous nous avez donné mais moi je reste
persuadé que celui qui rentre dans un
soi disant de boulangerie n'est pas
informée mal informés de savoir qu'en
fin de compte on lui a apporté la pâte
et que c'est une fabrication
industrielle moi c'est ça celui qui veut
acheter madame le ministre
sa boîte pour chacun est libre mais je
souhaiterais qu'ils soient éclairés et
qui sache c'est du pain industriel c'est
pas du pain qui a été fabriqué c'est à
dire que le boulanger s'élever à 00h30
heure du matin pour préparer sa patte la
reposer à 7,8 c'est l'information
et puis la deuxième chose en alumine
vous savez très bien vous n'avez pas dit
mais vous le dire vous savez que
normalement quand le gâteau était
congelé doit y avoir un petit ours
vous me direz vous voyez l'ours dès que
vous voyez lounge avec vous et on va
acheter ces gâteaux parce que l'ours
n'est pas mise ont peur ils le disent
eux mêmes
je lisais interviewé alors c'est pour ça
que je sais ça ils ont peur de dire bah
oui mais c'est il pense que ces congés
depuis longtemps même si c'était
fabriquer la veille moi la seule chose
que je souhaite c'est qu'on perd pas
cette tradition du pain qui est une
tradition friable dans le monde entier
je parais est apprécié et respecté et
donc c'est pour cela que ce matin je
voulais vous interpeller mais vous
demandez mon soutien pour défendre le
pont peut être tranquille vous l'avez
merci monsieur